it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week you get to hold your
breath and take aim with Sniper Elite 3
coming out on old and current gen and PC
snipe around North Africa carefully
gauging the terrain and environment
choose the correct muzzle and compensate
for wind distance and gravity to
accurately calibrate your perfect shot
in the balls not sure take out Hitler's
one ball jun 27th also this week
Megatron is back I guess you recovered
from getting his head and spine ripped
out as the Autobots and Decepticons
battle it out and a new game world based
on the generation 1 storyline for those
wanting a sequel to the Cybertron series
this ain't it but it looks like Brutus
is in it so you got that going for you
only one world will survive pick yours
june twenty-fourth and this week you get
to travel to 1914 to join four heroes
and their trusty dog walt in search of
their loved ones in a world torn apart
by world war one friendship love
sacrifice and tragedy befall each one as
they help each other to retain their
humanity against the horrors of war
enough to make a grown man cry but not
this man get back in their teeth start
cutting onions jun 25th also this week
become a valiant Knight with a trusty
shovel in the aptly titled of shovel
knight take on those evil nights and
those evil blobs and what those like
ferrets attached to the helicopters
don't even look evil they just look like
confused mice catches hover copters
anyway they're evil and so are these
mages and this creepy guy in this
monster and the bad guy shall I start
digging jun 25th
finally get your adrenaline pumping
through city tracks like chicago dubai
paris and barcelona with grid Autosport
also featuring circuits like Mount
Panorama red bull ring and the autosport
Raceway choose from 80 cars and race
across five unique disciplines touring
open-wheel endurance tuner and Street
and yes there's demolition derby as well
shift into gear jun 27th for further
details visit gamespot's new releases
page release dates are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change see
you next week
you